اصحاب المعالي والسعاده
الاخوات والاخوه
مساكم الله بالخير
ارحب بكم جميعا في الذكر العشرين الانطلاق
قناه العربيه
20 عام
شاهدت فيها المنطقه والعالم احداثا
تاريخيه مذهله
تغيرت فيها الخرائط وتبدلت مراكز التاثير
واصبح الاعلام احد اهم الاسلحه في الميدان
ولدت العربيه من غرفه اخبار ام بي سي
لتكون المتخصصه والشامله في مجالها
ومنذ البدع
كانت مشروعا وطنيا سعوديا
بعد ان ظهرت القنوات الفضائيه الاخباريه
الناطقه بالعربيه
والتي سعى بعضها
لتوجيه الراي العام
وفقا لاجندات معينه
كانت في اغلب الاحداث تتخذ مواقف سلبيه من
المملكه ومن دول الخليج
كانت لغه الاستهداف واضحه ومحاوله تزوير
الحقائق والمواقف التاريخيه
مدروسه ومنهجه
لذلك كان مشروع اطلاق العربيه في اساس
قرار
وطني سعودي
قبل ان يكون مشروع اعلامي عابر
فصوت الاعتدال السعودي يجب ان يبقى حاضرا
امام اعلام المزايدات والسعرات الزائفه
واجهت العربيه طوال مسيرتها
وضعا قريبا خانقا حيث وجدت نفسها بين هجوم
الاعلام المناول للمملكه
في الخارج
وهجوم التيارات المتطرفه عليها في الداخل
لكنها مضت بثبات ودافعت بثقه عن مساحتها
المرموقه في فضاء الاعلام العربي
وذلك بفضل من الله
ثم بفضل القياده السعوديه التي رات هذا
المشروع الاعلامي السعودي العربي
الدولي منذ بدايه
اليوم بينما بلادنا تعيش هذا التحول
العظيم تحت قياده خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وسمو ولي عهده رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير
محمد بن سلمان
فان العربيه تضاعف الجهود كي تكون بقدر
التحديات الجديده وكي تكون الوسيله
الاعلاميه الاكثر قدره ومصداقيه في
تعبيرها عن القفز التنمويه الهائله وعن
الدور السياسي الرائد المحوري الذي تلعبه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في المنطقه
والعالم
في الختام اتقدم بالشكر لاعضاء مجلس
الاداره ومجلس التحرير والمدير العام
والمدراء الذين تعاقبوا على اداره هذه
القناه
الذين تركوا بصمات ونجاحات ساهمت في مسيره
كما لا يجب ان ننسى الزملاء الذين ضحوا
بارواحهم لتبقى العربيه الاقرب للحقيقه
شكرا لجميع منسوبي قناه العربيه
الساده اشكر لكم حضوركم ومشاركتكم معنا
الاحتفال بهذه الذكرى والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]